PE PE incredible around you're sexy
touch me tee me me up hi we are Wy hi
everyone we are we we are we are we are
Winn hi everyone I'm a wi win hello I'm
10 hi I'm yyang hi I'm Shin Hi I'm hre
we're here with BuzzFeed and we're here
to play with
[Applause]
[Music]
puppies they just coming oh you're
like so small
hello oh but they're so they're so
shy you so
cute oh
he it's okay you don't have to be
scared no one's come from you like my
thumb you like my thumb right is there
someone come come here you have to you
have to check
this so we had like one Beagle and then
we had like three cats in our house so
we like a big fan of like animals I
think this guy really likes me he feel
like they're actually really
professional and Bella always give 100%
so like on that day we had like like two
cats named Lou and Leon and then one
like beagle is like Bella Bella was like
all day she was so energetic she just
run around and then there's like Lou
he's like a siami cat he keep like
hiding around it was like a tough day
because we trying to like fil the cat
they don't look at the camera so like
the photographer had to just lie on the
floor just trying to take a picture of
like the front side of the cat but I
feel like it's kind of like a great
memory for us because I we get to
capture that moment of our pets so I
think it's really good I think now is my
best memory ever I'm so happy right
now Bella she's doing great healthy
healthy she's never say she learned a
lot though learned how to live without
me so except obsessed with me obsess
with me but that's good because she
really likes you I also had like a new
like kitten his name is Levy he's like a
blue suami cat so now we had like four
pets in our place
yeah raising
Bella honestly B is not an easy dog to
raise I spend a lot of time with her but
she's doing great right now recently we
just finished like our fan meting tour
right yes so we've been to 10 cities and
everywhere went like the fans are so
loving so I feel like that's one of our
most satisfying accomplishment until
now when you're training a dog it's all
about the food if you have food you can
do anything you want
[Music]
food was very exciting because I don't
know anyone at that place but then um we
have like an after dinner and stuff and
they get to meet like friends
around um he's again it's his Instinct
my new actor friends he's
like he's very nice and we keep like
sharing like different stories about
life dude you're going home with me I
like you no no
eating let say let him say first he
practiced English for today's interview
let's go the stage is yours I'm really
shy yeah and it's very exciting I hope
you guys like this drama yes are you
poopy good job no no e come here
touching I bet like in mbti he's a e
yeah they're all e they're all e po
pees these my shoes wherever I go like
even if I go to like Tour on um other
places I always have like three pairs of
shoes to match my outfit because I feel
like shoes defin person
yeah actually I have a lot of pink
clothes pink is the best because he
likes pink so much on his birthday I got
him like shoes with like pink
[Music]
shoes you
want it's okay I will put regular so
like our debut song because we were so
so young and so unexperienced back then
it's going to be fun watching it back I
would say um Love talk and then miracle
I feel like the future generation going
to like those two songs I won't
recommend good time oh because you will
be happy when you listen to this song I
think right I would say Horizon because
Horizon is a ballad song I think ballad
song Always can touch people for me I
would like to say only human because I
wrote the lyrics
oh tennis tennis I think it's very
interesting I want to cook he's strong
I'm bad at making food but I want to try
it he's making a lot of breakfast
nowadays so it's good I want to be a F1
driver before when I was little but now
I think it's kind of hard but still I
will like to pursue that dream though in
the future for me I want Bella to try
some match it's like the um the dog
competition where they jump and then
yeahum I want be do that B can
definitely win definitely yeah any what
for me snowboarding but you're good at
it though uh I want to like professional
sowb yeah in a professional way oh I
literally seen him like start from not
knowing how to like even balance on the
board and then now he's really good you
can tell like the behind the scene
because I went to like a ski resort both
of us were some like professional like
ski suit but no one know how to
snowboard so like the outfit is 100% but
the skill the skill like
[Music]
0% tell them about like when you first
met with me
yeah and I arrived on on Korea it's the
same time my English is very poor but we
use the body language yeah they Ed to
Communications Communications because I
I want to go out and eat with him
outside so I was like oh no joging yeah
joing joing joing you mean
joging and he was like eating yes eating
I was like no joing yes I love eating
but he was really young back then yeah
we were like he's 15 and I and I was I
think I'm 16 wow High my first meal in
Korea I made with them yeah and Y buy it
for me he's a really like extrovert
first when he came he was like oh come
on man what's up I said I didn't say
what's up no you said what's up you can
call me DJ you call me you can call me
DJ Everybody DJ sh y shin and me we used
to live in one room the same room so uh
I think I'm the one who can wake up like
early so Shin always like woke me up oh
yo Henry don't be late come on come on
wake up wake up H it's a good
memory cute we've always been like cool
and sexy oh yeah we no that's true
that's true that was your think you have
to you have to know like you're
sexy like the whole vibe is sexy just
proud just PR of it even if you ask
anyone they say like oh if you talk
about 10 oh he's I'm not going to ask
anyone do you think I'm sexy no I won't
say that you have to the vibe thank you
that's why like I want to see like us
doing like cute concept but I I think
cute is very normal these days I think
we could do something funky funky kind
of vibe just like you're not trying to
be cool but you kind of chill but at the
same time you look very cool
[Music]
touch me teasing feel me out that's what
I want to say I can hear
from
way me up oh you can't listen it's not
for you it's not for you I think miracle
was nice too I believe
in like something
more good life was nice too I want to
know what that's like what that's like
no
problems they was like what are you guys
talking
[Laughter]
about the dog one with the it's like a
dog that does like this and and the one
that you said like yeah the the
like you know right that one that one
come on come
on y Yang go it's a wend right now we
playing the dog right
now he we were in the LA I wish they
have a name I can call the name and call
the name I can bring here I
wish he's like a rocket or something I
don't know why he's super
fast I'm going to call him um Tenny
Tenny why Tenny you want to take him
home yeah I want to take him home I
think he's a boy he's a boy right yes
he's a boy rocky rocky he's Rocky yeah
oh you're
tired he's tired how about number 1 2 3
4 1 two come
[Music]
here
McDonald it's very convenient there's
there's uh food there's food called
creps in Paris you can just taste the
act so good yeah like oh come on come on
come on oh P PP okay I
had oh we heard that in La the soft tofu
soup is is very good in La so we're
going to try it
tonight so the upcoming album is like
the second full album so it's like a
definitely like a new era for waybe
because like all the songs are very like
different from what we did before fres
don't
fight fight too don't F don't
[Music]
fight I can make like all the fried rice
into Roto
no the point is like because it's so bad
it's so toxic that people kind feel like
drunk because like the reso was so bad
that when he eat it he feel like wait I
kind of feel drunk because your result
is very bad for him he's really good at
flying cars we actually practice in our
dorm it's like how to fly cars it's like
he got really good at it and I keep
practicing yeah he keep practicing think
for winwin oh English English you never
spoke English before on any interview I
can become
snake oh
for me I don't know like any talents I
have I have too much I think I'm good at
making decisions almost all the
restaurants that we went to decision is
made by me persuade persu persu I have
one but I think every one of you can do
it it's about flexibility you want to do
it now yeah right now okay let's go my
right arms can touch my right ear but
cross the neck oh show it show it he
wants to see Ito you want to see
it wow oh
inquir I don't think I can do it I can't
do it I can't do this
though
who I feel hurt I don't know why this is
my only Talent right
here I have a lot of people like in my
mind right now because I'm a big fan of
NBA so like LeBron
James or um Damian Lillard yeah my
favorite players right now it's going to
be funny if we have like a whole NCT 20
people just like sit around and there's
like 20 puppies then we we need a bigger
Studio than this I actually hope that
our leader because he didn't came this
time but like I hope that next time he
will be here with us with them Rocky PP
Jun 10 junor and number three oh he's
like can you name me better all of our
puppies right here are adoptable and
they're rescued so if you want to adopt
them please hit up hit living Foundation
they're very cute and you can save like
a lot of Life be the new Mommy and Papa
oh Mommy and Papa Mama mother and father
father I want to say thank you to
buzzfeast for having us today we're
going to have our new wavy album so look
out for all the new stuff that we going
to show you guys see you next time see
you next time hey P say byebye PE say
byebye byebye
[Music]
byebye
h